Boom!
Holy shit.
So screw it.
Holy shit!
Bingo.
Hey, uh, Henderson's
not a… a curse, is he?
Curse? No. No, no, no.
He's fine.
Mental?
Absolutely.
You guys stay here with Max.
Keep an eye out for trouble.
You keep an eye out!
-It's my goddamn theory.
-You heard Nance.
-Who put her in charge?
-I did.
Could you maybe, uh…
clarify what sort of clues
we're supposed
to be looking for here?
"The world is full
of obvious things
which nobody by any chance
ever observes."
Sherlock Holmes.
You guys realise, if there's
a gate down there,
it's technically
a water gate.
Watergate!
It's north.
I'm positive,
I checked the map.
You do realise
that Skull Rock
it's like a super popular
make-out spot?
Yeah, so?
Yeah, well,
it wasn't popular
until I made it popular,
all right?
I practically invented it.
We're heading
to the wrong direction.
Maybe you infiltrated
his mind.
He invaded your mind, right?
Is it that big of a leap
to suggest
you somehow wound up in his?
Like Freddy Krueger's
boiler room.
Freddy Krueger?
He's this
super burned-up dude
with razors for fingers
and he kills you
in your dreams.
Dustin, seriously?
Sorry.
It's a movie. It's not real.
Boom!
Bada bada boom.
I was right.
Skull Rock was north.
Seriously? You're serious?
This is Skull Rock! OK?
You're totally, absolutely
100 per cent wrong.
-Right now!
-Yes.
And no.
Oh, my God.
That thing's got
batteries in it, right?
I'm not even answering
that question.
This compass
worked correctly
when we left the Wheelers'.
It was correct when we got
in the car on Curly, but it
started to slip
the further east we went.
Now, it's way off.
When I was leading us here,
I wasn't wrong.
The compass was.
So you're using
faulty equipment.
Dude, you're still wrong.
Except it isn't faulty.
You guys understand
any of this?
-No.
-Pretty straightforward.
Oh, straightforward. Really?
Well, what's confusing
to you?
Why is this wizard
obsessed with clocks?
Maybe he's like a clockmaker
or something?
I think you cracked
the case, Steve.
The chances of success
are 20 to 1.
Never tell me the odds.
Remember when I said they
wouldn't be stupid enough
to go through Watergate?
Yeah.
I overestimated them.
Where did everyone
get those?
Do you need
to be told everything?
You're not a child.
-The freak, right?
-Exactly.
-Shit.
-So before that happens,
we need to find Vecna,
kill him and prove
your innocence.
That's all, Dustin?
That's all?
Yeah, no,
that's pretty much it.
So screw it.
Screw what?
Screw high school!
What? What?
Dustin? Where are you going?
Just trust me!
Come on! Just talk to me!
Tell me things!
Wear a helmet!
Vecna is his
five-star general,
a five-star general
with the power
to open gates.
Holy shit!
-Holy shit!
Here goes nothing.
There we go.
And if my theory is correct…
-Abracadabra.
-Holy shit.
Anybody understand
what he's talking about?
-No.
-No idea.
OK, seriously?
How many times do I have
to be right on the money
before you guys
just trust me?
Jesus Christ, this kid's
gotta get his ego in check.
-It's his tone, right?
-Screw it.
Let's kill
the son of a bitch.